you know when I think about virtual
reality I think about humans as dreamers
I think about the human desire to
actually aestheticized italicize reality
to actually put mind and purpose and
function and it has on debt into the
world right like human beings take the
raw material and inject it with purpose
and signification so it's it's it's
reality rendered more real
it's the hyper real it's the mediated
reality the cultural reality in which we
live and so when I think about what's
happening with virtual reality I feel
like this is the ultimate consummation
it's the moment where our gifts and
desires and technology finally spills
over so that we can actually live inside
of our own minds I think about fully
immersive virtual environments where
everything around us would be like the
matrix a matrix of our own creation
shaped and molded by our dreams right
the iconography of our use the pop
culture references that inspire us the
songs that made us sing all of these
things will be the wallpaper of our
minds will window dress our
phenomenological theater will live
inside of a pop song this is virtual
reality it is reality enhanced
reality made better that's what I think
you
[Music]